Where's that cat I'm not dying
to meet it or anything.
- Can we wake her up?
- Um...
- It's a miracle
you haven't already.
- Jillian.
Hey, Mommy.
- Don't you "Hey, Mommy" me,
Daddy,
barging in here
with these whores
like the beginning
of some crude stag film,
just ten feet away
from where your cat sleeps!
- Okay.
- Oh, hey, hey!
We heard all about Denny's and
we just wanted to meet her.
- [mocking accent] Oh, did you?
- Yeah.
- [mocking accent]
Did you hear about Denny's?
[normal voice]
Do you have any cats? No.
- I--
- No, I didn't think so.
Because if you did, you
wouldn't be dressed like sluts
and following home strange men
to pound Mangria.
Blake, can I see you
in the kitchen for a moment?
- Mm-hmm, yup.
- We're not strange.
- Yeah,
we're very non-strange.
- By the way,
we are just minutes away
from the Mangria, ladies.
- Yeah, so, you know,
we didn't wake her up.
And I didn't think
it was that--
- Yeah, that's right, Blake,
you didn't think.
Denny's was left for dead
in a dumpster,
and you didn't think
that maybe you shouldn't
abandon her on the first night
of being her daddy?
- Hey, I mean,
I just figured, you know,
you're such a good mommy--
- Don't you patronize me!
- Okay,
how would I patronize you
when I don't even know
what that means?
Okay?
[stammers]
What do you want from me?
- I want you to be
a good daddy,
not some whore-mongering
night owl!
- Hey!
All right, at least those...
[softly] whores...
aren't crazy!
- Oh! Oh, that's right!
Because I am crazy, right?
- Oh, yeah!
- Okay, yeah, 'cause I'm crazy.
You know what?
- Yeah, oh, what you gonna do?
- I'll show you crazy!
- Oh, yeah!
- Denny's needs her dad!
- No, no, no!
Throw 'em all over the place,
Jillian!
- Denny's needs her dad!
- You fricking psycho!
Don't you throw
the nice plastic plates!
- Denny's!
Because she needs one!
- There's one
from Anders's birthday! Okay?
- Ohh!
- No, let me help ya!
Let me help ya!
- You want to help me?
That's fine!
- Just throw 'em
all over the place,
'cause I work
at a goddamned dead-end job!
I got the shortest straw,
didn't I, when I got you?
You're throwing plates!
[cat meows]
- She's awake now. Denny's!
- Oh, come on!
- Denny's!